one las vegas man contacted us at
channel 8 about what he discovered on a
private golf course a homeless camp well
the itunes vanessa murphy has more on
what she found and why there is
confusion about cleaning up the area
the las vegas national golf course is
minutes from the strip
i mean it's peaceful and quiet houses
like these border the property
you know you just look out your back
window and
you know that pretty much says it right
there herbert bashar says he's a
caretaker at this home on
ottawa street it's a great environment
to be around the nature
here but what he also found and i was
absolutely shocked
trash blankets and during our visit
someone
who appeared to be sleeping in this tent
this is somebody's home complete with
the outdoor barbecue grill
the golf course is surrounded by a fence
bashar tells us he's seen individuals
here on spencer use this
bookcase to step here and hop over
but during our visit we see one gate
wide open
this is is not the sanctuary
for homeless people the i-team reached
out to the las vegas national golf
course
general manager coy wood told us over
the phone
the golf course just doesn't have the
resources to keep up with the issue
in an email he wrote it's quote an
ongoing problem that we have been trying
to get the county to help control for
the past six to seven years with no help
end quote and in regards to the homeless
police will help try to remove them
only if there is a threat to workers
it's certainly an
issue and it's not going to go away the
i-team also contacted clark county
spokesman dan kulin says this is private
property and responsibility falls
on the golf course he also tells the
i-team the county is responsible for
this fence
and after we told him it was open the
county would check
on it while there is a disagreement on
who should
clean this up the gm says any help from
the public would be greatly
appreciated vanessa murphy 8 news now
we have the full response from the las
vegas national golf course on our
website 8newsnow.com